Hi, I'm Mano Marks,
and it's my pleasure today
to introduce
Bjorn Sandvik.
He is a project manager
at the United Nations
Association of Norway.
He's got
a Masters in Science
in Geographic
Information Systems
from the University
of Edinburgh,
and he's a web developer
and author
of the Thematic Mapping blog.
And he is here today
to talk about
using KML for
thematic mapping
and explain
how KML documents
can be generated on the fly
using the now open source
thematic mapping engine.
Sandvik:
Thank you.
First of all,
I want to thank
Mano and Michael
for inviting me
all the way from Norway.
It's nice to be here.
I'd guess it's
20 degrees warmer
than in Oslo
before I left.
Um...I'm going
to give this presentation
and I will focus on how
KML can be used
for thematic mapping.
And, um, so I will show you
different techniques
of how you can use
the thematic mapping techniques
in KML,
and I will also show
how you can use
the thematic mapping
engine--
which, as you said,
which is now open source--
to generate these
on the fly in a web browser.
And I also want to talk
about some
Google Earth issues,
some improvements
I would like to suggest
so it could be more easy
to use for thematic mapping.
Um, I will start with
a common
thematic mapping technique
called
"proportional symbols."
And I will identify
three different ways
of making these symbols
in KML.
And the first one is
to use the image icons,
to scale them,
and, um, this technique
is my favorite.
And I think it's
the most useful
way of making
proportional symbols in KML.
Uh, this one just shows
with the default push pins.
And here they are scaled
so they are proportional
to the population
in each country.
Uh, the background here
is the NASA City Lights,
and, um, this
is one thing I like
with using your browser
for thematic mapping--
is that you are
able to combine
raster data and
vector data very easily.
Um, yes.
So what you can do
is that you can,
just, uh, reference
another image,
uh, and then scale them
according to a numerical
or a statistical value.
So basically,
this can be any image.
So you can have
geometric images
or they can be
pictographic.
Uh, KML also has
the possibility
to colorize
the image icons.
And that is also very good
for thematic mapping.
So here that it--
you could represent
two different variables.
But here this--
the same variables
are represented by
both color and scale.
So what--basically
what I've done is just
make a white circle
on the transparent background,
and then they are
scaled and colorized
in KML directly.
So this is just a short
KML of--how it's done.
So the symbol is--
sorry--
referenced
in a shared style,
and then they are
colorized and scaled
for each place mark
or each country.
There is one problem
with this in Google Earth,
and that is the--
it's a problem of--
that the size
is affected by viewports.
And that is--
the reason is that
there are two different ways
of changing the size
of the Earth.
You can either
zoom in and out
or you can actually change
the size of the window.
And I can
give an example.
So if I'm zooming
in and out,
you will see the--
the size is adjusting.
But if I'm changing
the size of the window,
you will see
they maintain their size--
all the icons.
And I'm not sure if
there is a special reason
for this behavior
or if it's, uh,
like a bug.
But the--
this is a problem,
especially with the new
Google Earth plug-in,
because very often
you won't use the whole screen
to show the maps,
and you will just use like a--
in the frame or something.
And then,
you can't really--
you don't really know
how big the icons will show
up on the screen.
Uh, another problem
is with Google Maps.
If you want to use
these techniques
to visualize the KML
in Google Maps,
uh, Google Maps only--
it has--it has a fixed size
for all the icons.
So they won't be scaled.
And you are not able
to colorize them either.
So basically,
this technique only works
so far in--
in Google Earth.
The other technique
is to actually
draw the polygons
using the KML
polygon elements.
So basically,
what I'm doing here is
to calculate the latitude
and longitude points
that makes up
a circle.
And this is done
through a function.
So by changing
the number of points,
as you can see here
in the bottom,
you can obviously change the--
the shape of the symbol.
So this sort of works.
There is a problem.
What I like with the other
image icons technique
is that the icons are always
facing the user.
But here they are more
like lying on the ground,
and especially
in the 3-D interface.
It's really hard
for the user
to compare
different countries
when they are seen
in perspective.
Um, and it's--
another thing is
that it's--
I think it's probably
the most com--
most complicated way
of drawing a circle
is this function,
because basically,
for every single circle,
you have to calculate
all the latitude
and longitude points
to make up the circle.
So one improvement
to KML code, for example,
this could be done with
one line of SVG, for example--
could be to add support
for this directly in KML.
Uh, the good thing
of this technique is that
this one, even though it's
not so good in Google Earth,
it works very well
on Google Maps.
So the squares here,
they show up as true squares,
while in--on Google Earth
they will kind of get skewed
because
of that perspective.
Uh, the third technique
that we're looking at
is to use the Collada
objects or models
to make
proportional symbols.
These are normally
used, like, for the cities
and buildings,
but since you have possible--
you have the possibility
to scalethese models,
you can also use them
for thematic mapping.
So this is an example
of population shown as cubes.
So here I'm using volume
as the thematic
mapping parameter.
Another one, you--
of course you can have
every model.
So this was downloaded
from, uh,
Google Warehouse
and then scaled.
So this is showing
the number
of mobile phone
subscribers.
Uh, one difficult thing
about using the Colladas
is that
it's more difficult
for the user
to compare 3-D symbols,
especially when they
are also in perspective.
So and--one missing feature
is the possibility
to actually be able
to click on the models
to get the value.
So far, you can only click
on the image icons
and the polygons.
But that would be a nice,
like, extension to have.
So this is basically
how it's done.
It's--I import
a model into SketchUp,
and then
they are positioned
and also scaled,
so all the different objects
will have the same scale.
And then I also give them
a default color.
And by doing that,
I'm able to change the color
later on when
I generate the maps
because Collada
is also in XML format
so I can actually
read it into memory,
change the color, and then
save it to the KM set files.
To do that on the fly.
Okay, so that was
proportional symbols.
Uh, the next one--
popular thematic
mapping technique--
is to use chart maps.
Um, KML has no support
for charts, uh, natively.
But what's very good
is that you have
the Google Chart API.
And that is--it's
quite easy to embed or include
charts from the API
into the KML file.
So that's what
I've been doing here.
Uh, the size of the charts
is still proportional
to the total population,
while the charts themselves,
they show
the age distribution
for each country.
And the charts
can also be included
in the--
in the balloon.
So another example,
with the bar charts.
So it's good to use--
to show change over time.
So this shows the declining
infant mortality rate
for African countries.
Uh, a good thing
I like with, um...
with KML is the possibility
to have extended data.
And that is especially good
for the balloon style,
where you can reference
this extended data.
It's a much more, like,
cleaner way of making
these types of maps.
So that I would also
like as an extension--
that you could actually use
this extended data
within
the whole place mark,
not only within
the balloon style.
It will be much
easier to make--
kind of make these maps,
and easier for people
to kind of understand
what actually
is happening here.
Okay, the next technique
is choropleths.
It's probably
the most used and misused
thematic mapping
technique.
Um, you will see lots
of examples of choropleths
on the web
also for KML.
Um, you will
also see here that
I have like a--
uh, color legends,
so this thematic
mapping engine
is also able to make
the color legends on the fly.
We'll show you later on
how this is achieved.
Uh, another technique is
related to the choropleths
where you--
instead of using color,
you use the heights
of the polygons.
Um, so I was
able to do this
by using
extruded polygons,
which is supported
in--in KML.
So here the height
is proportional
to the statistical value.
So this map is showing
the infant mortality rates
in Africa.
What I think is improving
the view for the user
is to add color as well.
Again, this could be
like a different variable,
but I think the best thing
is not to--to mix
when you use
these prism maps
so actually it's
showing the same variables.
Another example--
this is showing the population
in municipalities
in Norway.
You will see Oslo here--
the capital.
So these techniques
can be used on all scales
on the whole globe
and also--
The problem with the prism
maps is there's holes,
polygon holes.
And the reason is that
if you have a polygon
on the ground,
you have the attribute
called a "clamp" to ground,
so it's actually following
the surface of the Earth,
the great circle.
But when you
extrude polygons,
you don't have
such an option.
So only the edges
of the polygons
are extruded,
but not the interior.
So when some countries
have, like,
a low statistical value,
they will have
a low altitude value,
and these holes
will appear.
So this one
is just a suggestion
of how this could be
solved in KML.
Then, instead of specifying
the altitude
for each vertex
of the polygon,
you could have
another attribute
where you only specify
the altitude once
and then the whole polygons
will be extruded
to that altitude.
And then
you could also have
an attribute, for example,
called "clamp"
to altitude.
So the whole polygon
will actually, like,
follow the great circle.
The next technique is
similar to the prism maps,
but this is using
bars instead.
So here I'm combining
the reg--
the technique for
the regular polygons
and adding
the height attributes.
So this one is showing
the number of internet users
per 100 population.
Um, what's possible
with the bars
is that you can actually use--
show two different variables.
A problem with this
is that
there is a lot
of countries in Europe.
So you get, like, a lot
of attention towards Europe,
because even though
it's a small country,
uh, with a tiny population,
it might still have,
like, a big bar.
So what you can do
is to have population
as the radius
or the diameter
of the bar,
and then have the height--
and here also the color--
to show
the statistical value.
The last technique I will
present is animated maps,
and here I'm using the quite
simple but very powerful
KML time primitives
to make thematic maps.
So I will show you
a few examples.
So this one is one example
with the prism map.
So this is the infant
mortality rate in 1960
shown on this map.
So by dragging the slider,
you can see how
the infant mortality rate
is declining...
until 2005.
And I think this is--
it's a quite nice way
of doing it.
You could do the same
only with color,
but it's easier for
the eye to spot changes
when you use height
and color.
Uh, another example is,
again, with the mobile phones.
So if I zoom in to...
this one starts in 1980,
I know.
You will see a tiny mobile
phone in--in Finland.
[laughter]
And also here you can see
the--how it changed things.
Scandinavia is quite good in
the beginning of the 1980s.
And then
it's really exploding
across Europe.
So you would have
this view in 2005.
So the highest number now of--
of mobile phone users--
this is not per,
like, per population.
It's not standardized.
This is total numbers.
It's now in--in China.
And, um, United States,
number two.
Okay, so that
was the techniques.
Um, I figured out when I was
working on these techniques
that it was quite complicated
to create these maps.
Uh, I did this programically
in using PHP
to generate the KML files.
So what I thought was
it would be much easier
if this could be done in
an easy-to-use web interface
for the user.
So that's why I created
a thematic mapping engine,
which was open-sourced this--
this Monday.
So it's available
now on the web
under, uh, GPL license.
Um, I will give you
a short demonstration.
Um, there are--there are
two ways of using this engine.
You could either use it as--
in a web interface
or you could use it in a--
as an API,
which I will show later.
So this is
the web interface.
So what you can do
is that you can
select
a statistical indicator.
So I can, for example,
take...
the infant
mortality rate again,
and then select a year
you want to show,
and then you can, uh,
choose one of the techniques.
So all of the techniques
are shown--are here
except the chart maps.
It's not yet available.
So I will take the prism.
You can set the maximum
height of the prism
and you can select
the colors
you would
like to do--use.
The color scale.
By the--entering
the start and, uh--and color.
And you can also choose
between different
classifications
for the data.
So I will use
equal intervals,
five classes,
and I would also like
to show the values
and the names
of the countries
on the top of the prism.
So you can use--
do like this,
and what was great
when I was working on this
for my thesis
was that you--
we got a Google Earth API
back in June.
So--and that was very nice,
because then you didn't
have to switch between
two applications.
You can actually
see the data
right away in the browser.
So if you click "Preview,"
it will make the KML
in the background
on the server
and then show it instantly
in the browser.
And if you zoom in here,
you will also see, like,
the--the names
and the values.
So now I'm just waiting
for the--Google Earth's API
to support
the time slider.
It's--I don't think it's--
you're not yet supporting it.
So to show
the time animation,
you have to download to--
to Google Earth instead.
So that's another option.
Can just click on this
and it will open
and download
the KML file.
So basically,
on a higher level,
uh, this engine--
this is how it works.
So it takes
statistical data
and it needs the border
of the features
and it needs
a set of parameters
of how the map
is going to be.
And then all this
is fed--
fed into
the thematic mapping engine
and then it returns
uh, a KM set file
which is then delivered
back to the browser.
Uh, so far there
are two ways of, um,
interacting
with the engine.
You could either use
the web interface
or you can access this
through a--as a PHP API.
So if you have
a PHP application,
you can, uh,
use the engine
and use it with
your own data, for example.
And one possible
extension would ma--
would be to make this
as a web service
so that you could do this
directly on the--
on the internet
by passing the data
to a web service.
Just click through this.
Uh, so
the web interface...
uses Ajax
and JSON techniques
to kind of have this, um,
rich, uh, interface.
So it starts
by just asking
for all the
statistical indicators,
and then it's delivered
back to the browser.
And then when the user
selects one indicator,
it asks for all
the available years.
And then aft--
when the user, uh,
push the "Submit" button,
uh, all the parameters
are sent to the server
and then the link
to the KML file
is returned to the browser.
And if the Google Earth
API is used,
it just instantly loads
the--the KML file.
And this is what's
happening on the server.
There is a form handler
that's--communicates
with the browser.
And then I have divided
it into two classes,
so you could extend it
more easily to
and add other data sources.
So all the data
are fetched from--
so today from
a MyScale database.
But by changing this class,
you can--
as long as the data
is in the same format--
you could easily tie it in
to another data source.
So the first thing
is that it--
it asks for all the data
it needs to make the map,
and then the parameters--
thematic mapping parameters--
and the data are handed
over to the engine,
which then stores
the KM set file
on just the file server.
So this is an example
of how we can use the API.
So this is actually
all the code
required to make
a choropleth map
with a legend and title
and everything.
So basically what you do
is to include
the two classes
and then you--
this is the, uh, number
for identify--
for the indicator
and the year, and then
you add the parameters
of how we want
the map to be.
And then you are asking
for the map here
by passing the--the data store
and the parameters.
I will not go into detail,
but this is, um--
this one is showing
how the structure
of the KML is--
how it's--it's made.
So basically it takes--
to make--it makes the--
all the shared styles first
for each
thematic mapping technique,
and then it's two loops--
uh, one, the outermost loops
is for each year
and the innermost loop
is for each feature
and country.
And then it adds a place mark
for each country
in the--
in the inner loop.
This is just how
this is structured.
Uh, the legends--
that was a challenge
because KML has no support
for HTML overlays.
It will only
support images.
So what I had to do is
to generate on the fly
a PNG image
on the server.
So then I used
a GD open-sourced library
to make these legends,
and then packed it with the--
with the other files
in the--in the KM sets.
So this is, uh,
my suggestions
for how Google Earth
could be improved.
Um, the first thing
is the icon size
of the different viewports
that I demonstrate.
Um, I'm not sure if
there is a special reason
for this behavior
or if it's possible to--
to be solved.
Uh, then another one
is that it's--
it's really important
for thematic maps--
for the user
to be able to access
or to find--
see the value of the symbol,
so it's crucial
that the user
can actually click
on the symbol
and then see the value
behind that symbol.
and so far it's--
it's only really working
for, uh, the image icons.
You can click
on the polygons
but you need to press
the "Control" button,
and I don't think, like,
the--many users
really know about it.
And also, the other problem--
the extruded polygons.
If you click on them,
it's not--you can't click on,
like, click on the wall
or click on the roof
of the polygon.
It will only identify
the click on the ground.
So it's really hard to
be able to click correctly
on the prism.
And the same with
the Collada models.
It would be really great
if you could actually click
on the--on the model and
then open the--the balloon
as--as with an icon.
Um, another suggestion
is to have more base maps
because, for thematic maps,
it's--it's really important
that symbols are in focus
and the default satellite
imagery, it's--
it's very busy,
in a way.
Uh, so it's--
it's kind of hard.
It's not a big contrast
between the background
and the symbols.
So what I did here
was to use
the NASA, uh, City Lights.
So it--what would
be nice is to maybe
to have a few more options,
and maybe some en-entry
that is not so--
for example, the one
you have for Google Maps
for--for topography.
Uh, it's much better to use
for thematic maps
than the satellite imagery.
And lastly,
it would be nice
if you could have,
maybe, for example,
a Google Legend API
like you have
the Google Chart API.
So as long as you--
you have to--
as long as you--
there is no KML support
for HTML overlays,
it would be nice
if you could do this
as a service
as with Google Chart API
to--to generate legends
on the fly.
It will be much easier
for the--for the users.
I will show you
one more application
that is called
the "Earth Atlas,"
which is also available,
uh, for download, open-source.
And I think that's
the great thing
with the new Google Earth,
uh, API--
is that you are able to build
your own mapping interface.
And you, um,
have much more control.
For example, when you
just give the KML file
to the user, you kind of--
you are--
you can't really guide
a user in Google Earth
in an easy way.
So what I've done here
is to kind of make
a little Google Earth-like
interface in the browser
using a library
called "Ext."
So here we'll see
you will have
the possibility
to open and close
and have various
options here.
So you can,
for example,
select infant mortality
right--right here
in the browser.
And you can also choose
between different backgrounds.
So you have the
Earth City Lights here.
It's loading.
Okay. Don't think
that's working now.
And you also have access
to all the Google
Earth functionalities.
So you can turn
on and on borders
and have the various
options here on top.
So it's very easy
for the user to--
to have access
to the Google Earth API.
Okay.
Here, it's coming.
That was all.
But we'll
have some time for--
if there is
any questions.
man:
Um, I see you've read
a couple of lines of...
Sandvik:
Pardon?
man:
Have you read...
[speaking indistinctly]
Um, how are you addressing
the issue of normalization?
[speaking indistinctly]
Sandvik:
[sighs]
There is a problem here
because it's kind of--
what I'm actually doing
is to give
the cartographic tool box
to the user, so in a way,
I'm--I'm kind of
expecting the user--
that the user is knowing
what he or she is doing.
So...
yeah.
So some of the indicators
that are available
are normalized
and others are not.
So, in a way,
I'm kind of suggesting
I'm--I'm expecting
the user to know
what will be
a correct view or not.
[murmurs]
man #2:
[speaking indistinctly]
Sandvik:
Is more--
man #2:
[speaking indistinctly]
Sandvik:
Than the other.
Um, I think
the mostly popular one
but also misused
is the choropleths.
Uh, when I had presented
these on the blog,
I think I got, like,
the most attention
on the prism maps.
People like that--
that map.
But the--that was also--
this is also
the techniques
were also criticized,
especially the--
the prism maps
and maybe also
the Collada objects--
especially because this
is done in a 3-D interface,
and you have the problem
that it's not only
the size of the symbol--
it's not only
the statistical value
that is affecting
the size of the symbol--
it's also the distance
from, uh, the viewpoints.
So if it's further away,
the symbols will be smaller.
But that's--that's a good
thing about image icons,
because they're not
affected by perspectives.
So when you have
the circles that I showed you,
they will have
the same size
uh, when--when
they're visualized.
man #3:
[speaking indistinctly]
Sandvik:
What I mean by "misused"?
man #3:
Choropleths...
Sandvik:
Um, especially
also like a problem
with normalization,
uh, and other issues.
For example, um...
a--a large country
will have a lot of focus
because it's, like,
taking a lot of space
[chuckles]
on the screen.
Uh, and--but by--
but, if you,
for example,
use a proportional symbol--
and especially
if it's also, uh...
you had these techniques
with the bars,
where you could have
the radius or the diameter
showing the population--
you will have
a more correct view.
Uh...
Mmm?
man #4:
So, um, do you--
so as far as
the web service part goes,
have you given it thought
as to, I mean--
do you actually plan on
creating a web server?
Or have you
thought about it?
Sandvik:
[chuckles]
man #4:
Maybe platforms, too?
Sandvik:
Um, right now
I have not yet decided
what to do.
Uh, and it's also,
like, a matter of time
and finance how much
I will continue on.
My--my--
what I like the most
is to actually make
the visualizations,
uh, more than
the code behind, so.
I think it would be--
I would let it--give that
task to someone else
maybe to make this
as a web service.
Hmm.
man #5:
Can you talk about
that data source?
[speaking indistinctly]
The U.N. database...
Sandvik:
Yeah, I forgot to mention
all the data is from
the U.N. data portal
that was just launched
back in February.
And, um, it's
a great service.
But they--
they don't have any
visualization capabilities.
But you can download
the data in an XML format.
So I just
wrote the script--
well, I uploaded this data
to the MyScale database.
Um, so basically,
that's what I'm doing--
been doing.
man #6:
How easy is that...
Sandvik:
Um, it's not too difficult.
It's, uh--the--
it's explained
in the documentation.
But basically
what the script--
the--this data connector
is doing
is that it's querying
the database
and then it's making
an associative array
of the data.
So as long as--
if you write another script
and just--returns
the same array of data,
you can feed it
into the engine and it's--
it shouldn't complain.
[chuckles]
man #7:
What would it take to do
a Python interface?
[speaking indistinctly]
Sandvik:
Um, yeah.
I know Google loves Python.
More than PHP.
[laughs]
Um, I don't know.
It's--this is about,
maybe 1,500 lines of code.
Mmm.
man #7:
And the source is already...
Sandvik:
Yeah, the source
is available, yeah.
man #8:
Can you cover
your choice of buttons
that you used
throughout...
Sandvik:
[murmurs]
I--the--the main reason
for having GPL
is that I'm using
the Ext JavaScript library,
and that is GPL licensed.
So in a way,
to be able to use that one,
I had to choose
the same license.
But it would be possible
to choose another license
for the server
part of the--
so if you're not using
the web interface
but only the API,
PHP API--
but, uh, for simplicity
I decided
to have the same license.
Mmm.
man #9:
There are--how many
types of visualizations
can the KML system support?
Sandvik:
That KML supports--
man #9:
That KML doesn't support.
Things it'd like
to do that...
[speaking indistinctly]
Or--or does it...
Sandvik:
I think it--
man #9:
Or just thematic maps.
Sandvik:
It's a lot--it's--
it's not really tailored
towards thematic mapping.
In--and thematic mapping
is--is not mentioned
in the--in the standard
document.
But there are
some flexible structures
that you are able to use.
But still
it's quite complicated,
and it's a little bit--
especially how
everything is--
is mixed together
with the styles
and the attributes
and the data.
So it will be
much cleaner, for example,
because you have to give
an altitude in meters,
uh, well,
for the prism maps.
It will be much better
if you have
a more flexible structure
just so you could
store the data,
and maybe the connections
between the data
and the height,
for example, separately.
Uh, so I think there is,
really,
a lot of improvements.
But what I like about KML--
it's quite simple
and ef-efficient
to use, so.
Uh, yeah,
I'm not sure what--
what would be
the best way to go.
man #10:
We saw with the mapping
of the countries,
that the environmental
issue's been covered--
um, non-country regions,
the oceans, boats.
Sandvik:
Mmm.
man #10:
Does this extend
to that easily?
What do you...
[speaking indistinctly]
Sandvik:
You need different data.
I haven't looked, uh,
a lot into that issue.
But you have, like,
other thematic mapping
techniques for that.
Like the asymmetric maps,
where you--
where you don't have
country regions,
but you have regions
following
the data themselves.
And--
man #10:
Atmosphere.
Sandvik:
Yeah, so--
and it is possible.
But then you need--
because what I--
basically what I need
is to have--how you have used
all the country borders.
So then you need, uh,
the boundary data
to be able to do it.
What many people do
is they just, uh,
make raster tiles,
for example,
because that we can use--
do for everything.
But I like especially if--
if it's improved
that you can actually
click on all the elements,
I think use the vector
features of KML
is much more efficient,
because the user
can interact with the--
with the maps in--
in a different way.